bonjour charles larcher bonjour à vous
vous êtes le président du coc des roms
le comité martiniquais d'organisation et
de défense du marché du rhum
etes-vous ce matin charles leur cher
président inquiet en colère remonter en
tout cas prêt à en découdre sur ce que
vous qualifiez d' attaque contre
l'europe de martinique oui enfin les
socio professionnels du monde du rhum la
filière canne sucre rhum planteurs
distillateur sucreries sont inquiets
parce qu'effectivement nous sommes allés
la semaine dernière donc dans les
ministères faire le point un peu sur le
ce dossier du contingent je rappelle les
données l'europe va dans un mois sans
doute sans aucun doute permettent que
nous augmentions de 20% là le volume que
nous pourrons vendre sur la france
hexagonale pour l'ensemble des rentes
des dom et en allant effectivement dans
six ministères nous avons nous sommes
rendu compte que la martinique n'aurait
pas une augmentation à hauteur des 20%
mais plutôt une augmentation à hauteur
de 15% tandis que d'autres territoires
tels que la gluck frère d ad à des
quantités effectivement supérieure de à
25% il faut le préciser il y a dix
règles sur la quantité de sucre de rome
que les antilles peuvent exporter sur le
marché français et européen
tout à fait c'est des règles qui date de
très longtemps 1922 et qui affectivement
limite les volumes que nous pouvons
vendre avec une certaine des tags de 50%
et aujourd'hui ces marchés et ce marché
hexagonal est un marché en progression
et l'europe des dom
lee dans ce marché doit progresser
autant que le marché il ya des règles
régir la fois par paris par l'elysée par
le président par bruxelles par l'union
européenne oui c'est à dire qu'au départ
c'est à la france de notifier de
demander à bruxelles a posté d'augmenter
ce qui a été fait il ya trois ans on a
eu trois ans d'instruction du dossier
au bout de trois ans nous attendons dans
un mois la décision de l'europe qui
devrait valider l'augmentation de 20%
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé sous
prétexe quelles plantes de plus de
cannes que la martinique la guadeloupe
demandent d'exporter davantage de
remettre en question des tonnages alloué
à chaque territoire entre réunion guyane
et martinique et guadeloupe bien entendu
oui en fait c c'est une problématique de
stratégies territoriales la martinique
il ya un siècle a choisi le rhum et
lorsque les sucreries ont fermé dans
tout l'outre-mer
la martinique a vu ses sucreries fermé
en premier et en plus grande quantité
tandis que d'autres territoires la
guadeloupe elle
réunion ont vu l'état soutenir fortement
notamment auprès d'un du plan mauroy les
sucreries et la stratégie de la
martinique était de dire nous allons
sans doute faire moins de cannes par
contre nous allons faire un run
d'excellence est la priorité de la
martinique et le romao c'est le seul
ramos au monde dans ce dossier vous ne
faites pas particulièrement dans la
quantité de de cannes produite mais vous
vous avez donc ce produit très très fort
un rom d'appellation d'origine contrôlée
seul au monde venez de dire à tel point
que ce rhum fait partie des arguments
pour vendre notre île en parle même de
spirit stories un peu comme le feraient
les écossais avec leur whisky
exactement c'est à dire qu'on a
travaillé alors c'est un gros travail
liée notamment à monsieur bourdillon qui
à 40 ans a pris le combat d'arrivée
l'ancien président du cd rom ses
impressions du côté sommes arrivés à
convaincre les cognaçais le calvados le
champagne le vin bordeaux que un rom
pouvait être aoc au départ il n'était
pas du tout convaincu de cela et c'est
ce combat de 20 ans a été récompensée en
1996 quand on a obtenu l'appellation
aujourd'hui quand on voit au japon en
australie aux états unis au canada nous
parlons dao ces roms a aussi rome
martinique et ça nous permet aujourd'hui
de présent dans 100 pays dans le monde
là-bas la martinique aujourd'hui à suhr
hommes dans tous les pays de route no
franchement charles larcher la qualité
l'excellence de ce rhum martiniquais
fait qu'on ne regarde différemment
lorsqu'on vous a lorsqu'on va dans ces
destinations états unis australie japon
et ailleurs
les pays sont épatés en fait de
constater que nous avons dans la caraïbe
fuck caraïbes françaises effectivement
ce produit d'exception pour eux ils ont
ils envisageaient plutôt une aoc sur le
territoire hexagonal
et quand on leur explique qu'on a
utilisé cette savoir-faire aoc sur la
canne à sucre et l'alcool de canne
ils sont vraiment épaté et nous avons de
très grands succès intéressant grâce à
ce roman
alors qu'est ce qui a amené cette
offensive un guadeloupéen si le simple
argument que là-bas à pointe à pitre en
cultive deux fois plus de surface je
pense que le la problématique a été que
la donne a changé de niveau mondial
les quotas sucriers sont tombés donc
aujourd'hui en europe n'est plus de
quotas sucriers
d'ailleurs le président hollande pour
soutenir la filière sucre guadeloupéen
est réunionnaise a donc ouvert son
secret tchèque puisqu'il a versé 30
millions d'euros
cette filière sucre la martinique dans
ce cadre là n'a eu aucun euro puisque
vous étiez sur la fabrication de rhum
d'excellence ainsi que nous sommes sur
un rom d'excellence aujourd'hui
effectivement la gaudeloupe sans doute
souhaite revoir sa stratégie et
redévelopper le rhum agricole mais ça
peut ça c'est qu'elle est louable mais
qui me ça ne veut pas se faire aux
dépens de la martinique et charles
larcher si cette stratégie guadeloupéen
existe signé parce qu'on se sent
autorisé de le faire parce qu'il ya des
hommes forts sur place plutôt offensif
et voulant s'accaparer de tout je parle
de la guadeloupe
oui je pense que chaque territoire de
défendre son bien donc la guadeloupe
effectivement défend très bien son sucre
et maintenance oam
la seule chose c'est qu'il ya l'état qui
doit effectivement un moment donné
prendre une décision équitable et
l'équité c'est de respecter les 100 ans
de travail de que les martiniquais ont
fait les vingt ans dao c'est que nous
avons est de faire en sorte que
l'adhésion soit bien de 20% pour tout le
monde sans une équité c'est aussi un peu
la faiblesse de nous mêmes le manque de
positionnement d'affirmation de nous
surtout de près de vue politique
disons qu'aujourd'hui on constate que
sur ce dossier
tous les élus sortants sont autour de
nous préciser parce que c'est très rare
de voir les quatre députés de martinique
plus les deux sénateurs ont ensemble
signé un document c'est presque une
première fois en tout cas durant dès les
dernières années que les parlementaires
soient d'accord sur un document oui et
puis le présent à ces thèmes est allé
voir la ministre il ya 10 jours pour lui
remettre un courrier le président de
l'assemblée que lise s'est engagé auprès
de nous à mobiliser les élus de la deûle
à ces thèmes lors de la plénière de la
semaine prochaine sur ce sujet donc nous
avons effectivement l'ensemble des élus
qu'ils comprennent que c'est un enjeu se
sent suffisamment et toi ce sera
suffisant
c'est pas évident du tout aujourd'hui
nous sommes en situation défavorable
quels seraient les risques si jamais la
guadeloupe aux petits et 25% que notre
production sera remis à café ne sera
augmenté que de 15 % les risques en fait
ces taxes d'emploi d'abord parce que
l'on va on va perdre en fait en termes
de performances sur le marché hexagonal
or c'est notre premier marché puisque
c'est là que nous avons aujourd'hui les
plus gros bonhomme qui sont vendues de
nos deux neurones et ensuite il ya une
perte d' influence aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient construites avec la hausse et
par l'euro martinique qui va sont là se
ressentir et notamment on a d'autres
fonds tels que les fonds européens le
font les fonds poesy que nous allons
aussi perdre dans ce cadre là et
puis voir réduit à néant tous tout ce
travail qui a été fait au cours des
derniers et des derniers mois des
derniers les dernières années notamment
sur le relance de la quête de la
plantation de canne à sucre le plan
cannes lancé par la région
oui c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui dit dire
que allah ou 1,1 litre de rhum
martiniquais est équivalent à un leader
européen
c'est c'est pas possible puisque
aujourd'hui la hausse et fait cette
différence fait cette excellence
aujourd'hui les planteurs de cannes ont
mis en place des process particulier il
ya certaines variétés qui peut utiliser
pas d'autres et donc on a aujourd'hui
sous certes une main des rendements
qu'être inférieures de territoire mais
on est choisi la qualité on peut pas le
sanctionner pour ajouter la qualité vu
de paris tout cela ça ça pourrait
ressembler un combat qui concerne ces
poussières deal tout là bas
aujourd'hui l'état doit faire un choix
nous ce qu'on demande à l'état c'est de
dire chaque territoire défense c'est
bien la guadeloupe le fait très bien
tant mieux pour elle mais elle risque de
faire très très bien la guadeloupe plus
qu'elle à la guadeloupe dispose de
députés estampillés en marche
olivier servais en martinique n'est pas
nice a aujourd'hui non j'espère qu'à un
moment donné on se rendra compte en
martinique que nous avons intérêt tous
ensembles sociaux professionnels et élus
à faire porter haut les couleurs et
martinique la martinique est un petit
acteur très dynamique au niveau
économique pas seulement dans le rhum
aujourd'hui il ne faut pas qu'on soit au
niveau national 1-1 politique alors il
ya eu 7
cette lettre signée par les
parlementaires il ya eu votre votre
courrier avoue qu des roms avec la sica
cannes qu'est ce qui risque de se passer
au cours des prochains jours
est ce qu'il y aura un travail de
lobbying qui sera fait qu'est ce que
vous allez faire mais aujourd'hui on a
on a d'abord dès que nous avons appris
la situation dangereuse pour le
territoire qui est la marraine à venir
ce coup là en disant qu'on était en
instance de discussion entre
martiniquais guadeloupéens guyanais
réunionnais et le fait est que mal que
nous étions nous lé avec des positions
que nous défendons la gaude hop avec les
siennes mais sinon pas d'accord mais
pendant que nous discutions certains
territoires sont allés voir les
ministères pour le pour faire du
lobbying
effectivement pour leur territoire et
uniquement leur territoire est
aujourd'hui quand on est effectivement
ces rendez vous
d'année une telle attitude non ce que je
condamne c'est le fait que l'état se
joue condamnerait c'est que le fait que
l'état ne soit pas pragmatique
chaque territoire défense et c'est ces
dossiers mais il faut que l'état
arbitres correctement la difficulté
c'est qu'on s'est rendu compte
en un an le 6 ministères qui avait des
points de vue qui étaient erronés sur la
martinique notamment le fait parce que
le travail de sape a été fait parce
qu'on nous a décrit comme des personnes
ne sachant pas produire de la can ce
qu'il faut on en produit en petite
quantité mais nous avons progressé de
23%
ces trois dernières années de la
production la cad des dix hydrique et
n'investissent pas assez sur le
territoire nous avait dans investir 80
millions d'euros sur dix ans sur
différents items notamment la sécurité
l'environnement et la production sur
leur char lan vie presque de vous dire
mais a fait qu aux autre six autres
passent à payer 10 ah non mais c'est
vrai et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
doit on doit se dire aujourd'hui que il
faut sans doute être plus
plus conquérants dans le cirque on est
conquérant niveau commercial mais aussi
plus conquérants dans le lobbying
conflits au niveau national parce que
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui ce que nous
sommes en train de faire dire à l'état
vous devez faire attention à tous les
éléments du dossier avant de prendre
décision et surtout pas à la prendre
pour un territoire ou contre un
territoire il faut être équitable et le
+ 20 % pour tout le monde c'est être
équitable mais c'est sûr que nous avons
un travail à faire régulièrement
d'amener cette information au niveau des
ministères pour être sûr que les
blessures soient bien prises en octobre
2017 va marquer un tournant pour vous
vous sera dès maintenant qu'il va
falloir savoir peser
oui aujourd'hui le fait d'être aoc de
remonter l'excellence française ne
suffit pas effectivement le président
macro edouard philippe appel aux
produits à ce que les produits
industriels les produits
agroalimentaires soit d'excellence nous
sommes l'excellence du rhum du monde on
peut pas aujourd'hui se retrouver dans
cette situation cornélienne de devoir
aller voir l'état et lui dire respecter
cette excellence pour qu'on ait nos 20 %
comme tous les territoires
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos
charles marchand appel vous êtes le
président du coc des roms le comité
martiniquais d'organisation de défense
du marché du rhum bon courage
merci